weiter heute weiter und fuhr an die box
und damit herzlich willkommen zu einem
nein tschuldigung alles gut
ja man überlebt leute wir haben eine
andere location sind bei mir im
wohnzimmer weil hier ist die küche wir
dachten das ist wichtig dass wir sehen
dann mehr sind weil wir machen heute was
krasses machen würde eines oder stream
experiment hilfskräfte idee gekommen
kann nicht erklären ich habe ein video
gesehen wo jemand wisse dass ein
englisches video gewissen der hat whisky
besonders stream oder wie sagt man
gesprudelt ja ich muss aber sagen der
max und so was wie eine wurde der auch
immer vor drei vier tagen braucht sowas
deswegen bin ich leider nicht der erste
das video könnt ihr euch auch sehr
genannt worden falls ihr euch in der
beschreibung
ja und wir machen was heute mit anderen
sachen wir haben nämlich tatsächlich
auch bisky ja wir sind beide über 18
ich muss nicht du musst das nicht
probieren ich probiere das alleine
nahmen 16
mein leben von euch wenn ihr noch nicht
18 sein dürft ihr auch keinen whiskey
trinken aber ich bin über 18 und ich
wollte nur wissen wie es gespielt hat
wissen doch früher war das ein absolutes
no-go als juso alkohol
zu haben und heute ich habe mich
eigentlich nicht und ich mache doch
jeder macht doch jeder okay wenn es ein
bisschen halt heute tut mir das leid wir
sind heute im wohnzimmer dann haben wir
noch steht das schwerste stimmten mit
dieser einst es anfangs diesen dosen und
anderen land bringen
das ist löblich dann haben wir hier noch
kaffee dann habe ich gerade gemachte
sprudeln café werken es nicht grund noch
cacau reise da bin ich weiß nicht ob das
möglich ist probleme
also ich glaube dass wir nicht so ganz
funktionieren aber ich weiß es nicht
vielleicht doch das hier sagt man der
oder das so dass für das hier ist die so
dass trinkt der store ist der stream
ich bin live in dem stream der stream
aber das ist ich weiß es nicht lassen
gibt somit kann mich ja was ist
eigentlich dein hauptkanal dein letztes
mal war der suche meinen videokanal
heute dann scheint mir heute noch mal
der gesamten zu uns danach wieder
gemeinde sagen was gibt es für mich hast
du da noch seine demokratie
das reicht was geht also wird sich jetzt
kaffee drin und ab ich glaube dass jetzt
hier
als nachfolger habe es gar nicht anders
geht
ich habe sogar dieses macht war es hat
mehr als 1000 ich jetzt mal so
erschrocken ich glaube das ist das
zeichen dafür dass es hat sich ein lkw
okay du kannst es jetzt abdrehen also
dass ich jetzt schon mal an sich pro
alter wie das sieht auch sie cola
richtig wild welche dame nicht jetzt so
gespannt das schmeckt okay ihr könnt
auch ein super gerne weitere getränke in
die kommentare beim oder jeden machst
was man auch mal so ich konnte auch noch
eine richtige alten orients machen mit
einem verschiedenen alkoholischen du
hast du das probieren erhält melden
[Musik]
da ist noch was neues
es schmeckt wirklich nicht gut war aber
es gibt ja gerne noch drin
das ist nicht leicht ich finde das gar
nicht mal so schlecht
also das ding ist das ist komplett
schwarzer kaffee schmeckt ein bisschen
so als wäre das kein starker kaffee mehr
so komplett westlich von sich die
technik fall starb also man kann es
nicht empfehlen
lasst dann mal jetzt als nächstes thema
saniert wie bitte
das wird glaube ich dass wir ein
bisschen okay jetzt kaufen
ich muss dazu sagen ich habe das ding im
vorher noch nie benutze ich auch extra
fürs video gekauft macht man sich keine
laster klatschen ein ca ja das kann man
jetzt schon sehen dass hat auf jeden
fall geklagt mal wie möchtest du anfang
wieder oder darf ich diesmal ankommen
ladies first ok dann fange ich doch
direkter
nicht schlecht ich muss sagen ich finde
es besser ungespült ich auch aber es ist
okay
schmeckt die sonne besondere art von dem
können wir jetzt in die ski machen bitte
alkoholiker letzten videos texte nur
einfach irgendwelche töne wie apricot
noch sein
leute wir können auch cbd den ganzen tag
auf jeden fall mein video ich teste hand
produkte ich hoffe dass ich habe mir
gestern haben wir eine richtige gros
davon gegönnt richtig geknallt er was
das hat gescheppert und dann war dann
weiß er müde
dann wollte er mich zwingen abzunehmen
das aussehen das ist wirklich richtiger
whisky so das reicht olaf h
[Applaus]
weiter zu bist du sicher dass du tun
musst vor dass sie ein geruch doch dann
muss das probieren wir dachten ich auch
daran dass er gar nicht machen behalten
wollen
ja ich werde da merkt man schnell leute
darauf dass ihr genau jetzt alle den
kanal abonniert trinke ich jetzt
aufbrechen
also ich bin sowieso kein whiskey fällen
muss ich sagen ich mag es nicht so gerne
weil es louis mit aber ich finde das so
besser als um gesprudelt ist immer noch
eklig aber besser als um gesprudelt okay
dann haben jetzt noch cacau das kannst
du mir da die flaschen mit vorsichtig
bitte wieder so wie eben passieren und
stahl
man verspricht sich das heraussprudeln
ich habe jetzt schon gesehen nicht so ja
ein jetzt drückt weiter weiter weiter
das sieht aus wie ein milchshake oder
wir trinken jetzt ein sprudeln okay wir
können uns eigentlich in den
muslimischen das klappt schon ganz gut
was man hier in der whisky geist das ist
irgendwie folglich geworden oder
doch klar das funktioniert das ist gut
so voll dass obendrauf nicht was das ist
wirklich absolut gemacht das ist das
schlimmste was ist danach reicht und
dann hoffe ich stimme klingt einfach
gewidmet
das war echt nicht sogar leute das war's
eigentlich schon irgendwie ging ganz
schnell und ich hoffe das hat euch
passieren dass man muss nur noch auf
acht minuten kommen können super gerne
doch nach unterlassen folgt uns bei
instagram ist in der bestattung verlinkt
und auch vielleicht auch wie eingebildet
wir sehen uns morgen wieder mal gibt's
neues video und ja auf jeden fall
weitere getränke und so in die
kommentare die wir noch sprudeln soll es
besser laufen halt
[Musik]